let's see this video that set the
internet ablaze make sure the volume's
up please
okay ally show me your ring
over here now tell me what you do for a
living
oh i love my husband and how did you how
did you get that awesome job
well
i became a better human being
and i became feminine and also shocking
submissive so
that was the secret so what are your
tips to women that want to be a
housewife
to embrace it it's an actual job you
just can't get it in the public or
private sector like you need you need a
man to hire you for it but that's okay
because if you think about it you submit
to your boss who makes you clean stupid
shelves at your retail job right like
wouldn't it be better if you were
cleaning your own shelves at home and
what i mean and your in your boss
wants to sleep with you in a good way in
a good way
and where where do you meet these men
well i think women should work for the
men that they want to pursue i know that
sounds crazy but it's really easy so if
you think about it like you want a
lawyer right so then you should be a
paralegal or if you want a dentist then
you should be a dental hygienist
but these are considered i guess
high value status prevent professions
but i think that's a really good model
that not enough women utilize because
women will bully the woman who is the
secretary that married the doctor okay
but who has the last laugh like her in
her mick mansion with her husband who's
behind the babies like that's that's who
has last laugh
boom so that was the video that set
things off by the way that was on
pearl's instagram or tick tock just
pearly things
um
comments blew up there was a couple more
videos let's play that and then we're
going to open it up for discussion so
they the that was the viral video and
then
a lot of ladies said or the comments
were not exactly nice the most of them i
assume right
uh and one said
this is heartbreakingly sad so ally had
a response to that go ahead
the woman that are saying this is
heartbreakingly sad
i mean i don't know
i get my back blown out regularly i am
fully paid for survival i have my own
autonomy i also do my own work so like i
just don't see what's wrong with my
situation but they can ask themselves
why they're single if they won't
oh
how do you feel about the woman
all right and then there's one more and
then we'll get to the discussion uh the
response to my husband is not my boss
can we play that one
ally what do you like what do you say to
the women that say my husband isn't my
boss there is no need to be submissive
you're a team
i understand where they're coming from
but these same women don't understand
that oftentimes they'll put their
husbands on the back burner for like an
actual boss in real life that they have
to submit to and they constantly ask
their husbands to modify their lives for
that meanwhile the dude is forgotten
he's absolutely sexless and she's
feeding him out of the microwave that's
the problem if you can work and love
your man equally you want to talk about
equalism right if you can do that then
good but most women can't most women
can't even push the power button on an
air fryer
all right what do you say to the women
okay cool so ally
yes um how has your life changed since
these viral videos like what what kind
of response you're getting to this
because i think your whole idea is here
find a high value man be submissive help
him
and then create the happy life happy
marriage you want do i got that correct
i would say that's correct i just want
women to be able to marry the men that
they want and then to be able to stay
married because i think that's the
hardest part is maintaining attraction
but if you can get the guy of your
dreams then you should be fine but i
don't think my life has changed much
other than my message is out there i
knew it would get out there in some way
shape or form i just didn't think it was
gonna be in the back of an uber with one
of my friends a content creator and i
didn't think that it'd be so
so awesome to roast women on the regular
it's been a blast
[Music]